Lamento decirlo pero la era de los grandes
conflictos parece estar de vuelta:
Desde la invasión rusa de Ucrania, hasta
la guerra urbana en Gaza, pasando por la tensión
al rojo vivo en el Alto Karabaj, la amenaza
de invasión de Taiwán o las inacabables
escaramuzas, golpes de Estado y batallas que
en África encontramos por todas partes.
Queridos amigos, el mundo parece en llamas.
[Si, no nos vendría mal una sesión de meditación
colectiva.]
Pero, ya sabéis lo que se dice por ahí:
“El dinero es el nervio de la guerra”.
Esta frase, que comúnmente se le atribuye
al filósofo y político romano, Cicerón
se explica hoy con noticias como esta:
(Ayuda estadounidense a Israel y Ucrania:
Esto es lo que contiene el paquete de seguridad
nacional de 105.000 millones de dólares solicitado
por Biden. CNN)(Blinken en Ucrania: EE.UU.
anuncia 1.000 millones de dólares en ayuda
militar y civil - France24)
N3 (29 de julio de 2023 - EE.UU. anuncia un
paquete de ayuda militar para Taiwán por
valor de 345 millones de dólares. AP)
Y desde luego, si hay un país que está a
tope con los tambores de la guerra, este es
claramente Estados Unidos. Porque si las armas
fues en música, no os quepa la menor duda
de que EEUU sería el DJ principal de esta
salvaje macrofiesta.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en los últimos
4 años las exportaciones militares del tío
Sam han representado el 40% de todo el armamento
comercializado en todo el planeta.
(El flujo de armamento de EE. UU. al resto
del mundo es dos veces más grande que el
de Rusia, y multiplica hasta por 8 veces la
cuota de mercado de China. Está claro que
si hay algo que saben hacer los americanos
es fabricar armas. En eso América es imbatible.
Claro que además de vender armas, EE. UU.
también está sosteniendo o apoyando varios
esfuerzos de guerra. Digamos que en esta ocasión
la superpotencia norteamericana está librando
guerras sin poner un solo hombre en el campo
de batalla)
EEUU está financiera y operativamente metido
hasta el cuello en al menos tres zonas calientes:
Primero, no hace falta que os lo diga, en
Ucrania;
Segundo, en el estrecho de Taiwán.
Y tercero, en Israel.
El resultado es que el despacho oval, o casi
que mejor dicho la olla oval, está hoy sometida
a una presión geopolítica enorme.
Porque cada una, a su manera, estas 3 áreas
calientas necesitan - y lo digo porque ellos
mismos lo piden - la asistencia económica
y militar del Tío Sam.
Y es por eso que aquí en VPK nos hemos hecho
unas cuantas preguntas:
¿Cómo está EE. UU. sosteniendo estos tres
frentes bélicos al mismo tiempo? ¿Será
el gigante norteamericano capaz de financiar
estas campañas? ¿Qué coste están teniendo
exactamente?
Pues… Todo esto y más lo vamos a ver a
continuación.
Cinturones listos y ¡despeguemos!
Cada vez que salta una chispa en el mundo,
lo raro es que no encontremos a los Estados
Unidos metidos de por medio. Es lo que muchos
llaman la ilusión de creerse la policía
del mundo. Una especie de sheriff en el salvaje
oeste.
Sea como sea, la cuestión es que hoy por
hoy las fuerzas armadas de Estados Unidos
son las únicas capaces de llevar a cabo de
forma razonablemente rápida amplios despliegues
de tropas y material en prácticamente cualquier
rincón perdido del mundo.
Y lógicamente, esa capacidad logística les
da una influencia desmedida:
Por un lado, les permite poder intervenir
directamente en cualquier conflicto, por otro
les permite dar apoyo a cualquier gobierno
extranjero en cualquier momento.
Sin ir más lejos, la guerra de Ucrania ha
sido un buen ejemplo.
Pensadlo bien, el Tío Sam logró entregar
de forma rápida una enorme cantidad de armas,
municiones y provisiones de todo tipo al ejército
ucraniano en plena ofensiva rusa.
Por supuesto, toda esta capacidad, no se ha
creado de la noche a la mañana. Más bien
ha sido un objetivo desde los años 40s, cuando
el presidente Franklin D. Roosevelt impulsó
la idea de que EEUU tenía que convertirse
en el “Arsenal de la democracia".
Una idea que, en mayor o menor medida, han
mantenido hasta la fecha prácticamente todos
los presidentes estadounidenses.
En general, tanto para los demócratas, como
para los republicanos, esto ha sido siempre
una prioridad.
En cierta forma, podríamos decir que de Roosevelt
a Biden, y mira que ha llovido, la receta
de la influencia mundial norteamericana no
ha cambiado mucho: un poco de diplomacia,
un montón de armas y una pizca de “puedo
estar en tu casa antes que una pizza'. [Y
si no, que se lo digan a Noriega]
Por supuesto, todo esto se ha traducido en
un multimillonario gasto militar y, también,
en la financiación de un montón de conflictos
a lo largo y ancho del mundo.
Pues bien, el caso es que para llevar a cabo
esta última misión el gobierno norteamericano
tiene reglas que se tienen que cumplir a la
hora de entregar suministros militares a otro
país.
Hablamos sobre todo de la Ley de Asistencia
Extranjera. Esta ley le permite al gobierno
de Estados Unidos proporcionar asistencia
financiera y material, incluida asistencia
militar, a países extranjeros con el fin
de promover, lógicamente, sus propios intereses.
[Hermanitas de la caridad no son]
Ahora bien, la pregunta es ¿Cómo se lleva
a cabo esta asistencia? Pues, amigos, vamos
a encontrar fundamentalmente 3 vías:.
Primero mediante lo que se conoce como las
Ventas Militares Extranjeras. Mediante este
procedimiento, Estados Unidos autoriza la
venta de equipos sensibles a países aliados.
Es decir, hablamos de transacciones comerciales,
de pedidos a fábrica, pero que son intermediados
por el Departamento de Defensa.
En segundo lugar, tenemos lo que se conoce
como la Financiación militar exterior. En
este caso Estados Unidos de acuerdo a los
criterios del Departamento de Estado financia
o subvenciona directamente la compra de equipos
militares norteamericanos nuevos a terceros
países.
en tercer lugar está la Autoridad presidencial
para la retirada de recursos (en inglés,
Presidential Drawdown Authority). Esto permite
la transferencia directa de equipo militar
del propio stock norteamericano.
C1 (“Si el presidente determina e informa
al Congreso de [...] que: (A) existe una emergencia
imprevista que requiere asistencia militar
inmediata a un país extranjero [...] y (B)
el requisito de emergencia no puede cumplirse
bajo la autoridad de la Ley de Control de
Exportaciones de o cualquier otra ley excepto
esta sección; podrá ordenar [...[ el retiro
de artículos de defensa de las existencias
del Departamento de Defensa [...] por un valor
agregado que no exceda $100.000.000 en cualquier
año fiscal.”
Seguramente ya os habéis dado cuenta de que
la cifra se queda algo corta [por ponerlo
en perspectiva, harían falta 40 años de
ese presupuesto para poder construir los 2
nuevos Air Force One]]… Bueno, pues tiene
trampa, la ley es antigua. Por eso desde 1960
se han aprobado cerca de 20 enmiendas para
modificar los techos de transferencia. En
2022, esta cifra fue de 11 mil millones de
dólares.
El caso, amigos, es que la distinción entre
las ventas militares extranjeras, la financiación
militar exterior y la transferencia directa
no es un simple tecnicismo, sino que como
vamos a ver es algo que ha generado un debate
cada vez más caliente en Washington.
Los conflictos militares cada vez más numerosos
están obligando a Washington a reorganizar
sus apuestas.
Por eso la pregunta es; ¿Qué exigencias
suponen hoy Ucrania, Israel y Taiwán para
la asistencia militar norteamericana? ¿Está
la Casa Blanca agobiada por las tensiones
militares que se están produciendo?
Pues, queridos amigos, amigas, aquí tendremos
que ir punto por punto, porque lo cierto es
que cada carpeta que llega a manos de Biden
y sus asesores trae consigo distintos dolores
de cabeza… Empecemos si os parece por el
lejano oriente… ¡Atentos!
(T1: TAIWÁN, EL PRECIO DE LA DISUASIÓN)
Los mares de China han sido la prioridad número
uno para el Departamento de Estado en materia
de disuasión militar durante la última década.
Irónicamente, es el único espacio donde,
al menos hoy por hoy, los intereses norteamericanos
todavía no están en medio de un conflicto
activo.
En este caso, la distribución y asignación
de equipamiento militar a Taiwán es muy distinta
a la cooperación con Ucrania e Israel. Empezando
en primer lugar, porque la isla no es en sí
misma un país independiente, o al menos no
lo es para Pekín ni formalmente para Estados
Unidos.
Para el régimen de Xi Jinping, la relación
entre EE. UU. y Taiwán es algo así como
la relación entre un país soberano y una
provincia china. Esto obliga a los norteamericanos
a llevar a cabo toda ingeniería legal a la
hora de asignar fondos y equipos militares.
Luego, en segundo lugar, el teatro de operaciones
del estrecho de Taiwán es único, ya que
en este caso hablamos de una situación de
guerra insular, donde la marina y la fuerza
aérea resultan absolutamente claves. En contraste,
por ejemplo, con la utilidad que tiene la
infantería de tierra en las guerras de Israel
y Ucrania.
Pero bien, la cuestión es que desde 1979,
EEUU está obligado a poner y cito, literalmente,
“a disposición de Taiwán los artículos
de defensa y los servicios de defensa en la
cantidad que sea necesaria para permitir que
Taiwán mantenga suficientes capacidades de
autodefensa”.
Esto lo dice expresamente la Ley de Relaciones
con Taiwán que promulgó el entonces presidente
Jimmy Carter. Desde entonces, se ha orientado
la cooperación militar con Taiwán mediante
las Ventas Militares Extranjeras.
Es decir, Taiwán es un país relativamente
rico que puede pagar sus compras de armamento.
Lo que necesita sobre todo es poder acceder
a equipos avanzados.
(“Durante décadas, las ventas de armas
estadounidenses a Taiwán han sido la contribución
más visible de Estados Unidos a las capacidades
de defensa de Taiwán. En el periodo 2020-2022,
Taiwán fue el mayor comprador de Ventas Militares
Extranjeras de EE.UU y fue el cuarto mayor
comprador entre 1950 y 2022”. Caitlin Campbell,
Analista de Asuntos Asiáticos - Servicio
de Investigación del Congreso (19 de septiembre
de 2023))
Sin embargo, en los últimos años esta forma
de llevar a cabo la cooperación con Taiwán
ha empezado a generar muchísimas dudas sobre
su eficacia. Principalmente por dos motivos:
En primer lugar, existe un problema de tiempos.
Los pedidos se demoran años y años en entregarse.
C3 (“Recientemente se reveló que se estaban
preparando ventas potenciales por valor de
19.000 millones de dólares, y algunas partidas
se remontaban a 2016. Este largo cronograma
es incompatible con una sensación inmediata
de amenaza.” Mark F. Cancian (Senior Adviser,
International Security Program del CSIS).
Armar a Taiwán de esta forma implica que
pueden pasar años y años hasta que el equipamiento
se entrega y empieza a estar operativo.
Por ejemplo, desde 2019, EEUU está gestionando
la compra de más de 60 aviones F-16 destinados
a las fuerzas áreas de Taiwán. La cuestión
es que Lockheed Martin en septiembre de 2023
dijo que estaba redoblando sus esfuerzos para
producir -hacia finales de 2025- cerca de
cuatro aviones F-16 por mes.
Y, claro, si tenemos en cuenta que esta empresa
también tiene que lidiar con las compras
de otros países, como Eslovaquia o Bahréin,
el flujo de cazas hacia Taiwán es más lento
que un funcionario un viernes por la tarde.
Y eso no es todo.
Por otro lado, una potencial guerra en el
estrecho de Taiwán exigiría llevar a cabo
un despliegue logístico sin precedentes.
El esfuerzo tendría que focalizarse en evitar
que la isla fuese bloqueada por la armada
china, garantizando en todo momento una línea
de suministro constante con los aliados occidentales,
al tiempo que se evite o se derrote cualquier
intento de desembarco enemigo.
¿El problema? Que para cumplir estos objetivos
hace falta unas capacidades que no concuerdan
bien con el equipamiento que está comprando
el ejército taiwanés. Es algo de lo que
ya os hemos hablado aquí en VisualPolitik.
N4 (6 de marzo de 2023: Taiwán necesita una
nueva estrategia de defensa para tratar con
China Los expertos estadounidenses critican
a Taiwán por gastar demasiado en artículos
caros [...] En lugar de comprar y construir
grandes barcos, aviones y tanques que pueden
ser fácilmente inutilizados por los misiles
chinos, dicen que Taiwán debería acumular
reservas de municiones y comprar armas más
baratas y móviles. Economist)
C4 (La defensa del "hombre de paja" está
consumiendo al ejército de Taiwán. Taiwán
debería evaluar su fuerza actual y todas
las inversiones futuras [...] una gran parte
de su presupuesto de seguridad se dedica a
capacidades que no sobrevivirán a los primeros
minutos de una guerra, o que ofrecen muy poca
capacidad para frenar una invasión. Michael
J. Lostumbo (Senior defense researcher – Rand
Corporation)
Ahora tras la experiencia de Ucrania, Washington
ha comenzado a tomarse mucho más en serio
la defensa de Taiwán, no sea que la falta
de disuasión por no estar preparados termine
provocando una invasión que obligue a Estados
Unidos a entrar en guerra.
Precisamente por eso, el pasado mes de septiembre
de 2023, Biden notificó al Congreso que haría
uso de su autoridad presidencial para cambiar
parcialmente el modelo de asistencia militar
a la isla. De esta forma la Administración
Biden hará entregas directas de equipos militares
de los propios stocks de las fuerzas armadas
de Estados Unidos.
Esto, además de agilizar algunas entregas
críticas les dará a los norteamericanos
una enorme potestad para decidir que se envía
al estrecho y con ello influir en la estrategia
taiwanesa.
La pregunta es, ¿hasta qué punto ha tenido
algo que ver la experiencia de la guerra en
Ucrania? Pues atentos, porque la vinculación
con Kyiv puede haber sido el punto de inflexión
a la hora de poner a Taiwán en el top 1 de
prioridades.
(T2: UCRANIA, CUANDO LAS PATATAS QUEMAN)
Creo que para nadie es un secreto que tras
la invasión rusa de Ucrania, Estados Unidos
ha enviado una enorme cantidad de armas hacia
Europa. Hablamos del mayor plan de asistencia
en el viejo continente desde el Plan Marshall.
Desde que estalló el conflicto en febrero
del año pasado, EE.UU. ha destinado más
de 75 mil millones de dólares en asistencia
al gobierno ucraniano. Lógicamente una parte
muy importante de toda esta enorme ayuda se
ha utilizado para enviar una gigantesca cantidad
de armas y munición.
Sin embargo, la solidaridad norteamericana
podría no ser ilimitada. Muchos republicanos
del ala trumpista consideran que la ayuda
Kyiv ha sido excesiva.
(27 de octubre de 2023: La ayuda a Ucrania,
en entredicho: Johnson quiere retirarla del
proyecto de ley de ayuda a Israel. NYTimes)
A ver, la Administración Biden quiere que
el Congreso apruebe 61 mil millones de dólares
más para Ucrania. 61 mil millones es mucho
dinero… Pero realmente no es una cantidad
tan importante… Al menos para la gigantesca
economía norteamericana.
En cierta forma la guerra de Ucrania está
siendo relativamente barata.
Sobre todo si tenemos en cuenta los resultados
que está dando esta ayuda. Y, ojo, no lo
decimos nosotros, sino el propio líder republicano
del senado Mitch McConnell. Fijaos.
Y en términos de pragmatismo político…
Tiene razón. Cuesta decirlo pero si hablamos
de realpolitik a Estados Unidos esta guerra
le está saliendo baratísima. En términos
de PIB apenas ha supuesto un gasto del 0,18%
en equipos militares y del 0,3% en total.
Pero entonces, ¿por qué tantos republicanos
parecen tener tantos problemas? Pues a ver,
supuestamente las quejas no estarían directamente
vinculadas a la ayuda militar en sí, sino
a las condiciones con las que se envía.
Y es que veréis, desde el primer día, Biden
ha hecho uso de la autoridad presidencial
y del
Programa de financiamiento militar extranjero
para abordar la entrega de armas a Ucrania.
Lo que en la práctica resulta bastante lógico,
ya que o se enviaban armas a toda pastilla
o Rusia habría terminado saliéndose con
la suya.
El problema es que esto ha hecho que la transparencia
no sea tan grande. Hay poca información sobre
fletes, entregas y proveedores. En cierto
modo la ayuda se ha entregado bajo una especie
de paraguas gris que los republicanos han
criticado duramente.
Claro que… Pensadlo un momento. Teniendo
en cuenta la guerra que se estaba librando,
quizás tampoco habría sido muy lógico que
Estados Unidos anunciara públicamente y con
todo detalle las entregas realizadas.
Luego, otra crítica es que las transferencias
están reduciendo el stock de armas del propio
ejército norteamericano en una cantidad que
dado los niveles de producción actuales de
la industria militar norteamericana puede
tardar bastante en reponerse.
Sea como sea, el caso es que esta falta de
transparencia - y sobre todo la creciente
crispación política, junto con el agotamiento
por una guerra que ya se alarga más de la
cuenta - ha hecho que los norteamericanos
cada vez apoyen menos, sobre todo los republicanos
y los independientes, que se mantenga la cooperación
con Ucrania. Fijaos.
Por supuesto, por sí mismo esto supone otro
quebradero más de cabeza para el gobierno
de Biden, a las puertas de un nuevo año electoral.
Pero visto el caso de Ucrania… ¿Hacia dónde
apunta el papel de Estados Unidos en la guerra
de Gaza?¿Está suponiendo esté conflicto
una especie de tarta envenenada para la administración
Biden?
Atentos.
(T3: ISRAEL… LO QUE FALTABA)
Como dice el dicho: “éramos pocos y parió
la abuela…” Si las carpetas y las reuniones
en el Pentágono ya no daban abasto con las
demandas de Taipéi y Kiev, el ataque de Hamas
a Israel del pasado 7 de octubre ha sido la
gota que ha colmado el vaso.
(El secretario de Estado, Antony Blinken,
no solo tiene que lidiar ahora con la nueva
cooperación con Taiwán y la creciente tensión
que se vive entorno a una hipotética invasión
china, sino también con la amenaza republicana
de bloquear los fondos a Ucrania y lo que
el primer ministro Benjamin Netanyahu ha calificado
como la “segunda guerra de independencia
de Israel”.
Ahora bien, al menos en este caso el camino
está mejor trazado.
Estados Unidos e Israel son aliados muy estrechos
y desde noviembre de 1983, opera un Grupo
Conjunto Político-Militar que anualmente
diseña y consensúa los programas de asistencia
entre ambos países.)
De hecho, Israel es el país que más excedentes
militares ha recibido de EE. UU. en la última
década, muy pero muy por encima de las capacidades
transferidas -bajo esta modalidad- a Taiwán
o Ucrania.
Además, según información oficial, hasta
octubre de este 2023, Estados Unidos tenía
con Israel casi 600 contratos vinculados,
por ejemplo, a los Aviones de combate F-35
; a los helicópteros de carga pesada CH-53K;
a los aviones cisterna de reabastecimiento
KC-46A; y a municiones guiadas de precisión.
Muchos de estos contratos son pagados por
Estados Unidos. De hecho, para que os hagáis
una idea, se estima que desde 1948, Estados
Unidos ha proporcionado a Israel más de 130.000
millones de dólares en ayuda bilateral. Si
tenemos en cuenta la inflación, hablamos
de unos 260 mil millones de dólares de hoy.
Pero, claro, eso no es todo.
Como ya os hemos contado aquí en VisualPolitik,
el riesgo de que se termine desarrollando
un conflicto a mayor escala, con Hezbolá,
Siria o, incluso Irán, ha hecho que la Administración
Biden redoble sus esfuerzos… Enviando directamente
un montón de efectivos militares y barcos
a la zona e incrementado también la asistencia
militar a Israel.
Hablamos de un paquete adicional de ayuda
de al menos 14 mil millones de dólares.
Así que ya lo veis, estos son los 3 conflictos
más calientes o más fríos en los que Washington
está metido hasta el cuello. Hacía mucho
tiempo que el entramado militar norteamericano
no se veía sometido a tanta presión en términos
de stocks y arsenales de munición y armas.
La pregunta es: ¿Hasta qué punto pensáis
que Estados Unidos debe apoyar a Taiwán,
Ucrania e Israel? ¿Cuál sería vuestro orden
de prioridad? ¿Priorizar recursos a políticas
domésticas a corto plazo o a exteriores con
visión a largo?
Déjanos tus impresiones en los comentarios
y abramos debate. Y ahora si este vídeo os
ha resultado interesante no olvidéis darle
a like y suscribiros a VisualPolitik si es
que aún no lo habéis hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.